I wrote it I sent it I am
so about ten years ago my writing
partner and I got our first taste of
success and we found out we were having
our movie made it's very exciting and
the day after the news came out I got an
email from a musician friend lovely guy
so this guy had had a song out I don't
think it wasn't like on the charts
certainly but it was me like passed
around from our friend group when I'd
seen him at a party I'd raved about him
like I love that song and he just
offered very generously you know to give
us the song if we wanted to put it in
the movie so instead of just writing
back thank you so much very nice I was
feeling myself so I forwarded his email
to my writing partner and proceeded to
make a lot of fun of him this guy's like
stalking us it's like so disgusting it's
just like give us a minute to enjoy our
successful when you're trying to cram
your song down our throats man ah and
then I look up and I see that I have not
forwarded it to my writing partner but
and in fact simply replied to him can I
push back from my desk and scream help
me somebody help me no one could help me
I called this gentleman and I got to him
before he'd read the email and I have to
come up with a cockamamie lie look I
know this is gonna sound crazy but you
have to believe me when I tell you my
writing partner is a monster she hates
when I discussed business without her so
I had to make you look bad in order for
her to feel like it was her idea to use
this song and I hope you understand I
told him please read the email call me
back you know as soon as you do protip
if you want to talk about an email
you've just received why not start a new
thread start fresh
you